olá como já se disse aqui o meu trabalho
é criar imagens pré vinhos trabalha numa
agência de design onde construímos todos
os dias com site o nome é imagem dos
vinhos
o nosso objetivo é que cada projeto é
fazer com que a garrafa acre seja um
amor à primeira vista para o consumidor
isso é um processo longo que começa
sempre com uma garrafa vazia como a
calça sem rótulo e que a pergunta óbvia
quanto é que vai a uma garrafa sem
rótulo não vale nada porque não sabemos
quem está lá dentro nem sequer sabemos
que é vini que que tá lá dentro é a
safras encontradas no túmulo de
tutankhamon tinha uma inscrição do ano e
do produtor e vinha de onde tinha saída
que eu vim por tanques
tevez que é fundamental informar porque
talento da garrafa e dar 10 as primeiras
garrafas de vinho do porto não apenas
porto escrito um voto zinho hoje em dia
pois tivemos que por exemplo aqui temos
vários vídeos do porto todos os réus
vinda de todos e aos do mesmo ano 97
oferece mas todos com particularidades
diferentes
temos que a embalagem também precisa não
só de informar como diferenciar se
olharmos para um ato ao prato era de um
supermercado
percebemos que com marcas novas
aceita todos os dias em diferentes
segmentos 3
temos que diferenciar também é pouco
temos que atingir o consumidor ainda por
cima porque sabemos que 50 a 80 por
cento das decisões de compras são feitas
no supermercado enfrentar prateleira e
que o consumidor se é que vai comprar
menos de dois segundos importante o
nosso objetivo em vinhos nos outros
produtos luz por exemplo a embalagem é
um complemento do do próprio produto
no fim não embalagem é a única
informação que temos a cerca do dobro do
que vamos adquirindo que está dentro da
garrafa
tanto o nosso objetivo é criar um amor à
primeira vista é fazer com que o
consumidor leve essa é nossa é nossa
o objetivo do design do rótulo é é criar
uma narrativa é criar uma narrativa que
comunique com o consumidor porque o
ajuda a dignificar o que é que vai
adquirir que está dentro da garrafa mexe
como é que se faz um de que o deck onde
é que vamos construir esta tal narrativa
na minha profissão
criatividade não é só a tal a serviço do
marketing e portanto essa história tem
que ser verdadeira e e tem que começar
na origem e por isso em cada projeto
você à procura de pistas que estão com
certeza na origem ou na chuva é vinho
que devia sair que não fazemos tantas
haiti mas também fazemos alguns aqui
tudo conta quer saber tudo falou com o
enólogo falco o produtor pois sua notas
8 abriga vetas quase como um inspetor à
procura de pistas e tudo interessa uma
nota uma história de vingança não o
terro ar
tudo é a conta para depois trazer todos
esses segmentos para o aqui um trabalho
com uma equipe de criativos designers e
começarmos a construir uma narrativa
visual que conte tudo isto tem que seja
uma decodificação sensorial da
experiência que vai ter depois é
consumir o fim triste exemplo que eu
acho que a minha maneira de contar como
é que acontece este processos criativos
na minha área e comece por este que é um
vinho fight for 2009 as minhas amigas
sandra e essas áreas andré tavares e
essas áreas de banho
a deputada mary elas a z e este projecto
começou uma conversa com a sandra onde
estávamos a trabalhar noutro projecto
numa vinha e aonde se assim eu vou fazer
um vínculo suzana nos ajudar como é que
não é cá ter começado chamar e eu
comecei logo a fazer um primeiro a
história porque isto é se elas a susana
é sandra vive no douro e suzana viveu no
dou muitos anos elas eram muito amigas
estavam sempre juntas e não trabalhava
junto esperamos trabalhar nos seus
projetos mas conviviam bastante mas por
questões pessoais e suzana vai viver
poço pelas ruas e elas é imenso sucesso
profissional nas suas vidas cheias
trabalho tanto uma como outra são prime
premiada em cima de acesso porque não
sabe é sandra tem um vínculo direto com
o marido e eu vim português mais
pontuado
isso é também ganhou o prêmio de melhor
do mundo e fica pronto este projecto que
elas tinham juntas eu preciso
efetivamente era um álibi para poderem
voltar a atuar juntas então cap da mente
me lembrar do nome crochê ou seja duas
mulheres juntas
vocês e crochê e pôr a conversa em dia
é isso foi um projecto ingressar fomos
readquirir vários livros antigos do
crochê previstas para nos inspirar
nesses design tem 2 sp2 passarinhos e
teve um foi que vários prémios design um
deus o penta ótica é o prêmio mais alto
na nossa categoria de pequim e foi um
projeto que deu muito gosto de fazer e
continuar a dar tanto em um inspirado no
universo muito feminino que é duas
mulheres juntos para ponto-a-ponto
construir qualquer coisa neste caso com
vinho eu acho que elas não devem saber
que nenhum então por que interessa é é o
que isso representa e simbologia que
está por trás desta imagem
outro trabalho
também houve nesta vez do alentejo
lá fui eu através de ver o sítio era uma
linha não teme nada mais nem sequer a
gatinha que está um projeto
relativamente recente
não vi uma adega uma casa um palácio o
produtor não era porto não é português é
o norte está ligado a outros projectos
nem que eu vou pregar que esta vinha
tendo o único e particular
tem uma coisa é que é em cima do mar
seja este vinho foi o primeiro projeto
na costa vicentina no alentejo mas junto
ao mar e os 20 têm uma enorme influência
atlântica e por isso a idéia central
deste destino desta marca que tinha que
ser
é a situação geográfica que ateste a
proximidade ao mar
vim da costa vicentina é mais eficiente
no o primeiro vinho na costa atlântica
da costa atlântica na costa vicentina ao
atingir a costa atlântica e que não sabe
onde é que fomos buscar esta imagem eo
porquê
a fusão do mar com o céu faz lembrar um
copo eu gosto muito rocknroll
provavelmente será essa a inspiração é
este
este este vinho tem uma característica
este é que por essa proximidade ao mar e
três dias levou a equipe naquela região
na altura maturação das uvas durante o
verão
o elenco é todo tantos outros 20 anos
estão a morrer de calor como atrações é
grande e este que tem muito desgastante
frescos
isso influencia bastante do filo 2011
vindo mais frescos consumirá
principalmente nas categorias mais altas
é e por isso este é este clima acabou
também por nos inspirar para construir é
gamer chamar nomes aos vinhos não é só
aquilo azul mas criamos três gramas
tendo entrada de ar na cor rosa chamado
do sangue 76 ou os sinais no céu azul eo
e e ainda mais alta de vinhos com uma
galera mais complexos chamados no fog
precisamente por essa influência do
usuário
outro projeto o último desta vez um
azeite também do fashion e que mais uma
vez a fiel ter com os construtores
negaram e lá fui eu o levava ao rival
era entre évora e estremoz eo lucro e os
proprietários um casal dentro do
professor professor do liceu que
herdaram está a levá lo conhecido os
avós e dos e dos bisavós talvez tenha
passado de geração em geração como uma
jóia e eu não sabia que ia de mal eu não
sabia o que queria dizer com aquilo só
mantinham acho por amor e por que já
tinha porque tem esse é um olival de
família e pensar
os enganou falou e chamaram 3
precisamos de uma embalagem preço nossa
sites e eu pensar existe um projeto que
os concorrentes com as inerentes
dificuldades de competir competitividade
que vão encontrar quando quiserem por
isso numa prateleira do supermercado não
é onde outras marcas muito mais forte e
com preço de custo muito mais baixas vão
conseguir que a primeira
então pensei vamos pensar no outro
mercado que são precisamente os turistas
que visitam a cidade de évora e vamos
criar uma uma garrafinha big blue que
seja 11 mesmo tempo uma recordação de
syrah inspirados no figurada de estremoz
que o jogo vai colocar dudu também
imaginei isso foi imediato enquanto
estava com ela a conversa não levar uma
estatueta de arte popular feita por
acusá los de imóvel há anos que
representa os sentimentos e ofícios e
enfim esta representa eu acho linda e se
conecte em dólares vendados com esses
traços distintivos de um coração normal
apresentaria se unirá do amor ou seja o
mesmo sentimento que teve por trás deste
projecto esta vontade manter o aurival e
chamamos de amor e sexo
o oovoo existe lá trouxe os rivais
quatriênio joão saúde
o detalhe é que fez isto desenhou a sua
interpretação do deste desta figura e
mexeu o o o site amor e ser também
ganhou alguns prêmios está outra vez
nomeado para o penta horas deste ano o
prémio internacional de que nós é muito
importante e
[Música]
que se consiga ver é transportado numa
numa numa embalagem muito simples
ecológica e econômica e que e que acaba
por isso acabou por ser um sucesso
também posso dizer que os seus
proprietários estão a pensar alargado
que disputou nos permanentemente com os
turistas shopping que visitavam é a
beijar imensa gente a tv é eu estou a
pensar em alargar a produção e julgar os
olivais os dois vizinhos e na pouco
tempo e ainda há pouco tempo eu fugi do
rio encaminha o maior do deste prémio
desta nomeação para o prémio e eles
responderam master of tanta eu ia
liliane percebi que tantas vezes não só
que tivemos encontrar isso pra mim é o
mais gratificante no meu trabalho esta
parte o o depois de pronto o que deve
mostrar aqui
como é que uma história ruim vant é que
tem que ser verdadeira e que está sempre
na origem associada a um design com
impacto e elucidativo é pode criar com
sucesso
pode ser um sucesso e claro que o
embalagem influenciam a compra
determina-se dos determina a escolha e é
engraçado que influencia mesma prova
andar mesmo profissionais por turma dos
profissionais são influenciados pela
imagem ou seja um provador profissional
pontua nome é diferente um vinco uma
imagem ou sem uma imagem numa prova cega
e essa imagem pode ser tanto positiva
como negativa pode ter uma influência
tão positiva como negativa
pronto o nosso objetivo é sermos que
este amor à primeira vista evoluam para
relações jurídico para sempre ou seja
que o consumidor quita a compra e
estabeleça uma relação emocional com as
marcas que nós desenvolvemos obrigado
[Aplausos]